each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
research I'm very happy to be able to
introduce to talks the first one by
Scott Shanker we'll be talking this up
talking to us about the data oriented
network architecture and then the second
talk might indeed to dukkha will be
talking to us about the rate control
protocol we're gonna plan on sort of 30
to 45 minutes for the first talk and
then 30 or 45 minutes for the second
talk as well and do you want questions
during the talk or hold questions for
you okay great take toys Scott thanks
okay so this this first talk will be an
exercise in the dangers of tenure and
the second target the second talk and
indeed is a terrific talk so I'm going
to make sure that I cut off at 45
minutes so you get a chance to see what
happens when you're still a graduate
student and you do real work this is
real that I'm going to talk about data
oriented networking the architecture
this is with a bunch of people at
Berkeley and the problem we're
addressing is simple that is the
internet was really designed for
host-to-host communication i want to
login to some other machine i want to
get a file from some other machine so
you're telling you that we're contact
this host where's the internet now as we
all know is used really for data access
which is get me this data and i don't
really care what host it comes from so
there's this mismatch between the design
and the usage and what it means is a
bunch of things that are incredibly
natural are very hard unnecessarily hard
in the current architecture moving data
migration data replication
authentication and updating they're all
possible we all have mechanisms as we
see below you know things like Akamai
BitTorrent coral codeine RSS polling we
can manage to do these things today but
the fact that people keep inventing
these new mechanisms can either be seen
as a sign that well it's solved or that
these solutions aren't really sufficient
in their it's unnecessarily hard for
something that should be one of the
basic functions of the network so this
work is founded around a single question
which is so given that that's the
dominant usage of the network
what would the internet look like if we
designed it around this you should so
taking that as sort of a fundamental
requirement of the mechanism this is
sort of part of the clean
late mania where you say you know what
let's throw everything out let's start
over from scratch it turns out that this
particular design doesn't involve any
changes to IP that that fell out in the
design not not wasn't one of our
starting conditions but everything else
changes
naming whatever there so you know as
part of the clean slate mania I will
bring this up at the end it's not clear
that we learn much from this exercise in
that I think you know I will propose a
way you could design a network that
would be very friendly to data access
but it's not clear given where we are
now how we can learn from those lessons
how we can take advantage of them now
there many other design issues besides
data access I'm not going to talk about
them here we've got many other research
projects that you know considering all
these issues nothing I'm going to say in
this talk sort of contradicts some
ertainly some approaches to these other
issues so it's not sort of making it
impossible to deal with those issues but
I'm not going to talk about it here and
the last thing that's important to note
is there really are no not new ideas I
mean every slide you're gonna see you
guys hello well that was in the triad
paper or that was in the whatever paper
and that's absolutely right I mean this
is stealing sort of shamelessly from you
know all of the things in the literature
but we've put them together and
hopefully a new way so let's start off
by saying you know what do users care
about when you're going to design a
system for data access one of the things
that a user would care about well the
first thing they care about is
persistence that is once they have a
name of data they want to be able to use
that name for all time they want to get
back you know file not found they don't
want to find out that the data move
somewhere they want that name to always
work as long as the data is available
somewhere they want that name to work
okay so today we do that badly
through HTTP redirects or email
forwarding or other ways of sort of
saying well it used to be here but now
it's here so I'll somehow manage to get
you from here to there the other thing
they care about is that if the name
works they then want to be able to get
the data they want to sort of be able to
get it both in terms of low latency and
also high availability that if there's
any copy of the data around they want to
be able to access it today we use things
like Akamai and BitTorrent in order to
help us find copies of the data
and lastly you care about the
authenticity of the data and here by
authenticity what I mean is the data
came from the source I expected it to
come from that is if I think this is
data from CNN that I want to know that
the data really did come from CNN
whether or not I trust CNN it's
something I'll talk about much later but
that's not something the architecture
cares all about you get to decide who
you trust all we're trying to do with
authentication is the data really did
come from the party you trusted so today
we do that by securing the channel or
through a PKI so if this is what users
care about then why what are the
barriers to doing this today so one of
the barriers is that naming is sort of
both rigid and weak these are the worst
of both worlds it's rigid in that it's
tied to a host so that moving data
becomes very hard because it's you know
a hostname path kind of name and so it's
tied to the host and the the name is
weak in that it doesn't help at all with
authentication you know if I go to a
site and then I get the data
I cannot tell by looking at the data and
the name that those two things go
together and that the data is only named
at the application level nodes if I do
the DNS than TCP than HTTP it's only at
the application level where where I've
said what it is I'm after and so then
any kind of data handling like caching
or and so forth has to be
application-specific and in particular
there's no low-level support for any
caste data discovery okay so that's all
got to be up at a high level so how so
we want to fix these two problems so
fixed number one is to fix the naming
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to steal from self-certifying file
system and from hip which is used
self-certifying names and all that means
is so we assume that all data is
associated with a principle that is
that's the person you trust and it has a
public key and then names are of the
form you take the hash of the public key
and then some label that's unique to
that particular piece of data and then
when I go and ask for data what I'm
returned is a four tuple which is both
the key the label the data and then this
whole thing is signed
now what happens here is that if you
hand me if I asked for data by name and
then some random stranger hands me back
this four tuple I can verify that indeed
this data came from the name I thought
it did then from the principle that I
thought it did so I don't care at all
how I got it I can take it from
strangers because on the face of it I
can verify by the name and bodies the
public key the four tuple coming back
has the public key so the two are linked
together and so with the signature I
know that you know if I'm getting it
from CNN I know that CNN signed this
data so naming now help to take care of
authentication and this form of the name
isn't it all tied to location so it's
not rigid so it's both stronger naming
and it's less rigid I will describe
later how you do resolution that is if
this doesn't include the location that
how do you find where the data is
that'll sort of be the main part of the
mechanism the talk
short hostnames or short email names or
short whatever and this means you need
some additional step to say give me the
given the thing that I can describe get
me to the portal so that they're
actually sort of - is she put it on a
business card and make it easy for
somebody to type Daniel I need some
extra level of interaction yes and and
and there we explicitly make the
decision that that kind of mapping from
some sort of short mnemonic to this four
tuple is handled outside of the
architecture that's not something we
want to standardize so if a AOL wants to
sell keywords they can do that if bol
wants to sell keywords they can do that
so my business card says AOL keyword so
that that notion of sort of we call it
canonicalizing a name so there's a sort
of a short mnemonic that should be a
market outside and there you don't have
you know sort of we don't have ICANN
arguing over you know sort of who owns
this domain because that's sort of a
commercial decision outside the
architecture here the thing that needs
to be standardized we've explicitly
wanted to make it sort of semantic free
let me get to that in the next slide so
what I claim is that this gives a better
separation of concerns that is the names
take care of persistence and
authenticity Trust which is the issue
brought up is handled by external
mechanisms and the point here
Trust is only needed when the name is
obtained that is when I get this flat
name getting it is that's when I have to
make the decision to do I trust this
once I'd make that decision I don't need
to worry about authenticity when the
data arrive that's sort of built into
the architecture and so whether or not I
trust a name can happen from a wide
variety of mechanisms like a friend of
mine says this is the CNN flat name
use it I trust it there's no way that
can be part of a standard and so the
things like you know do I trust a search
engine to hand me back the right name or
do I trust a reputation system those are
things that are going to be outside the
architecture and you're absolutely right
they have to be solved but I explicitly
think it's sort of a goal not an
unfortunate byproduct that those are
placed outside of the things we all need
to agree on because I think those are
going to evolve in different societies
may have different answers to that Devo
different legal systems will definitely
have different answers to that and
you're exceedingly unhappy with that so
I mean do you think the right answer is
DNS inclusion which is it's not solved
yet did you need something more
I'm not disagreeing with the
architecture I'm just pointing out that
there's no existing problem but to some
extent I view it's not just it's not
solved but it is insoluble in that there
is never going to be a perfect solution
and given that you want something that
can evolve and not something that we so
standardized now and so by having that
mapping between human level meaning and
some flat name I don't want to
standardize now because I don't think
we're ever going to have a hundred
percent perfect solution I think things
like reputation systems are always going
to be very fallible but they're better
than nothing and so we're just going to
have to sort of learn as we go but I'd
prefer that to be outside of the
architecture rather than in and then so
if you've taken care of persistence and
authenticity and if you've explicitly
not taking care of trust but you've
handed it off to somebody else then the
last issue is availability and that now
you can say to the protocols the network
protocols that's the only thing they
need to take care of that all this other
stuff has been done so now although your
protocols need to worry about is sort of
yet making sure the data is available
and that means you can do things like
aggressive use of caching and by
aggressive meaning because I can verify
it's the right data I don't care who
hands it to me I don't need to trust the
cache if anybody hands it back to me
like person on the street that's fine so
you can use very aggressive caching and
you want to go to nearby copies to both
lower latency and lower bandwidth and
backbone links
so the second change is to say once
we've got this different naming how can
we use it to do things like finding
nearby copies and do better caching well
it's to move the names down lower in the
architecture that is you don't want to
just name something up at the
application level and have everything
down at the lower levels be oblivious to
the names and so we insert a data
handling shim layer right above IP and
so then the donor later has two major
functions that is rather than using DNS
style resolution which is I give you a
name you hand me back where it is and
that means that the resolution mechanism
has to make the decision given who you
are I'll have to find the closest copy
to you we're actually going to route
to the closest copy so we're gonna use a
routing algorithm we understand how to
do large-scale distributed routing if we
you know the job is to take you to the
closest thing that we know how to do it
that's the right mechanism for it
so we're gonna resolve names by routing
you to the closest copy and we're gonna
provide a general caching infrastructure
so the rest of the talk is how do we do
those two things okay because those are
designed to support availability so
we're just gonna the rest of the talk is
really about how we accomplish these two
goals so we're gonna do it through two
new Network entities one of them is
called data handlers they're sort of to
some extent the new version of what DNS
servers would be and they operate at
this data handling layer of the donor
layer which is just a shim layer right
above IP and they do name based routing
and caching okay so you think of
logically there's one of these per
administrative unit and you know you
might think of an administrative unit
isn't hey assbutt then you can also
think of it as much finer granularity
below that you know in terms of
corporations I would have a th in my
house and so on and so forth so you can
go down to lower levels so in addition
to these data handlers you also have
authoritative resolvers that is if I'm a
principal I have one resolver that knows
where there's a copy of all my data okay
there may be many other copies all over
but there's one place I can go to
resolve where my data is it may be that
that thing holds all the data or it may
just have pointers to where the data is
but there's one thing that knows where
the data is and then there to new
Network primitives there's fine which is
given a data name I'll go find the
closest copy and the find request has
not just the day to day but it also has
the transport header and the application
header that is that when it finds the
copy it begins the application level
action whatever that is that you don't
sort of go look it up find out where it
is and then send another packet you just
start immediately and then there's
register which is where you say to the
network I have this piece of data you
know I'm a cop copy and this has to be
authenticated that is you have to prove
that you've got the private key
associated with that data or at least a
certificate from somebody that says your
authorised to serve that data and you
can register either an individual data
item or the authoritative resolver
basically says I can resolve everything
so if you route a request to me I can
forward you to to a copy of the data so
the way it works sort of as an overview
is the clients are configured with their
local D H yeah but so you will register
with your d8 local D H so in that
registration command as I'll show in
three slides later gets forwarded
through the network to set up routing
state so no I am telling the network I
have this copy and think of the D H as
my first hop router at the donor level
so I talked to my local D H as a way of
telling the network I have this copy it
will route that registration through the
network well I mean you have to prove
that you have the private key associated
with that data so you have to prove that
you're authorized to serve that data to
the network know the name the name of
the data has embedded in it the public
key so it can verify whether or not I
indeed have the private key associated
with that public key
right I mean hop-by-hop this is
revalidate so yeah yeah yeah so I mean
right I mean it's not that if I've
corrupted the first hop it then just
goes up know it so to check hop by hop
um and actually so - by keeping the path
you can then sort of have the higher
levels recognized sort of if there was
an incorrect command coming in sort of
where things might be coming from so
clients are configured with this local D
H and if I get a find request at ad eh
and I've got it in my cap so these DHS
also have a cache then I just respond as
if I'm a cache I respond to the request
if I don't then I try and route the find
to the closest copy so that requires
that there's be some routing table that
will tell me what which th I should send
this to to get it closer and when you
route this you can decide whether or not
you want to get the data on the return
path that is you can decide do I want
the state in my cache and if so you can
do that very easily which is you just
put your IP address as the source of the
fetch request the find request and then
you forward it on and so then when the
response comes back it'll come back to
me I will have state that you know where
the find originally came from I'll put
it in my cache and then I'll respond so
that I can fill my cache with all these
requests and if the name isn't in the
routing table that individual name that
I route it to the AR I say that you know
I don't know where that individual data
item is but I know where the
authoritative resolver is and I'll
forward it there so all of this
basically boils down to being able to
route so the loads if if I can tell you
how to route then everything works okay
so that's really the only missing piece
the routing is actually completely
standard so you think of these D H's you
know this is sort of representing the
you know an idealized version of an AAS
hierarchy but these DHS sort of know how
to route among themselves you're we're
just going to implement anycast routing
so you know when you register a copy
these registrations flow up that as you
send them to your parent and your peers
when I say you send them to your peers
you're going to use the same kind of
peering or
relationships you've got at the bgp
level and the same kind of forwarding
rules that is if you don't want to be a
transit as4 data you don't forward it
some peer that is your statement
affording it to appear is the statement
of I'm willing to be a transit AAS for
this data so they go up to the parent
that leaves behind routing state that's
sort of this one knows that there's a
copy of the data here and here this one
knows there's a copy here and so on and
so forth so the scaling issue is that if
you're a d-- age the only data you need
to have explicit state four is the data
that's below you and the hierarchy so
with the edges where we're gonna have
watch of these things you're gonna have
a very tiny amount of state so it's easy
to keep in memory that sort of handling
these requests is going to be trivial if
you're up at a tier one yes you've got a
couple of terabytes and handling
requests there is iffy but i will talk a
little bit about that later and then you
just do any cusp routing that is that
when it issues a find and it gets to
another that doesn't have a state it
just sends it to its parent until it
finds some state and this guy knows that
there's a copy down here and it just
gets routed there and so that you will
automatically get routed to the closest
copy
according closest according to the
routing metric okay so this is totally
standard routing behavior it's just it's
done at this donor level and so you
automatically find the closest competent
so basically this is very simple that in
sort of dona just says name resolution
becomes anycast routing on names which
makes easy replication that is if I have
ten thousand copies of this there's no
one server that's sort of trying to keep
track of where all the copies are that
you just automatically get routed to the
closest copy if data moves it rear edge
astir someplace new
when people ask for the data it just
gets taken there and so building a CDN
now isn't about the smart figuring out
from your IP address where you are and
you know managing all this it is just
setting up a bunch of servers that
register data that's what the CDN would
be caching is ubiquitous that is caching
caches are automatically on the path
think of it is given you know right now
I do a DNS resolution I come back and
then I asked for the day
so the caches have to be on my sort of
application data path whereas here we're
saying we're putting in the caches on
your name resolution path so that unless
you so assuming you have no other way of
finding out where the data is those
caches are going to be on the path
you're gonna have to go through them so
you're automatically are certain caches
on the path and so when you try and
build plot no other applications like
you try and do BitTorrent on this the
way you implement BitTorrent on this is
just a naming convention that is you
have a top-level name that names all of
the chunks of the data so I go get the
top-level name I get the chunks and then
I go ask for the chunks and donor takes
care of taking me to the closest copy of
all of those chunks so there's sort of
you don't have to do any of the routing
which service you go to just a question
of naming so there are all sorts of
bells and whistles you can add to this
that is you know right now I've sort of
talked about static content but what
happens if you want to worry about
update so both you know in validating
caches or you want RSS and here it's
largely inverting the normal caching
paradigm which is we're used to caching
data and a request comes responding what
happens if we cache requests and when
data comes we support it on so it's just
turning around that's exactly what RSS
should be that is it was the fact that
I've asked for this data if I put a TTL
on my request so it sits there memory
when new data shows up at the server it
knows that there's a request for it and
it will forward it on to the previous
hopper so you get the automatic RSS
behavior you would want and you sort of
build up this RSS tree you know
automatically so the you know the logic
is completely simple and you
automatically are able to do cache
invalidation and updating load balancing
which is sort of a big issue if you're
really trying to run a big CDN boils
down to sort of adjusting the metric on
each of the servers that is when I
describe the routing metric well each
server is also going to have a sort of a
number and that routing will be sort of
be taking shortest path routing and so
if I increase my metric it's a shedding
some load we have not
built this yet we are in the process of
actually trying to do it to demonstrate
that that's going to be sort of enough
to deal with this now
just that isn't enough because if I have
ten thousand servers over here with you
know a path length of five and one
server here with the path length of four
point nine I don't want to send all my
requests here and so there's some amount
of randomness we're gonna have to build
in and we're in the business of
designing that mechanism so that you can
actually get sort of load sharing up
here rather than this knife edge of it
see if they're all goes here it all goes
there server failure so what happens if
one of the server's goes down and done'
hasn't recognized it yet like you know
it's able to answer keep a lives but in
sort of when it returns data it just
returns garbled data so what you can do
is you can ask done' not to give you the
closest copy but to give you the chaos
copy that has given me the second
closest copy and the third closest copy
so if I get back bad data I'll just
basically be asking for take me to a
different server and if none of them
work I can just say take me back to the
authoritative resolver and if the
authoritative resolver gives you bad
data then it's the principal's fault and
it's not donors fault then that this one
a policy so you know typically when you
think about CD ends there's things like
Akamai which is a wide open and
everybody ought to be able to access it
but we all know the enterprise networks
have sort of tremendous amount of policy
that involves and who can access it or
do I want to put middle boxes on the
path and to some extent this sort of
first packet that announces might you
know this is what I want to do here's
the data I want to access and here's the
protocol I want to access it with is a
good place to insert policy so that's
what we're looking at now is it how can
this data handler then make decisions
about even or just denying the request
or maybe inserting a middle box like
saying you know fine I'll let you do
this but you have to go through a proxy
and so putting the proxy on the path and
that's going to involve dictating
something about the data path and so
we're in the business of designing that
now I don't really know how it's going
to turn out
and lastly sort of ad-hoc scenarios
there really are sort of two separate
aspects to this there are the semantics
of the register and find and then there
are the routing of them which is how a
register happens to find how they find
command finds a registered copy so in
places like ad hoc networks we don't
have any structure you don't have a
hierarchy to route you might use a
completely different dissemination
algorithm like you might you might
broadcast times and not do anything with
registers or vice versa or some other
random thing and so you might have a
very context-specific decision about how
you want to do the dissemination of
these things based on where you are and
I'm going to end with sort of two of the
sort of many open questions most of the
open questions are you know sort of
various sort of details like I went
through but two of the the ones that I
sort of get down to whether or not this
was a total waste of time or not was you
know does this scale and sort of every
part of this it's trivial to scale
except when you get to the sort of the
Tier one asses that are sitting there
they've got terabytes of data they've
got to handle a high bandwidth radio
request now obviously you're gonna put
these boxes on the edges of peering
links so that you know you're not
putting them on your backbone links
you're gonna put them on your access
links and so low speed access links are
no problem that's the one gig or 2.5 gig
peering links that's where you really
start to push things and I think it
really is going to boil down to what are
the cache hit rates both that sort of
given that we have all these caches
along the path how many you know
starting with some request stream down
here how many of them are going to be
left by the time you get to tier one and
then second you're gonna have a working
set in memory now sort of handling the
number of requests in terms of your CPU
is trivial it's this thing's so you're
gonna have some working set of data
names that are gonna be in memory and
how many times you're gonna hit that
versus going to disk and you know it's
just very hard for us to do estimates if
you get anything over sort of 80% hit
rate here we think we're fine but you
know in this new world where data is
named this way it's not clear that we're
gonna get the same level of hit rates
that people do now yeah
I want to bring down the internet and I
can just fabricate requests for things
that probably don't exist right so so I
didn't talk about this because it's sort
of not part of the design but it's a
part of our going an assumption that
well the two parts because one is we
assume that you know you have a contract
with your internet service provider that
gives you access to a D H and so there's
going to be some resource limitation of
how many requests I'm going to be able
to send and then clearly if I'm sending
sort of you know full out that that
should be stopped at the first top and
and you know so on and so forth if
there's sort of a certain limit but I I
think that partially what you may have
been asking is I can make requests that
I know will go to disk and so one of the
ways to respond to that is I know where
the authoritative resolver is and so if
I'm starting to get overloaded what I do
is I don't look for the individual data
name I just say I'm gonna send to the
authoritative resolver then the number
of things you have are just the
principle keys not the data names and
that I think is probably going to be
much more likely to fit in memory it
just shed load as fast as you can and
that way there's so then the question is
if somebody starts sending in requests
for principles that don't exist and that
I don't know what we're going to do I
mean that that would be the sort of
query of death I'm trying to break it
yes I am doing web crawler
you know Google and MSN search are by
their very bad localities I mean they're
just they have to be tier ones so they
can sort of well so I guess the question
is so you're only gonna go to a Tier one
if the data panel die I didn't say this
but the sort of the D H path between a
resolution will be exactly the AAS path
of the data the the data would have
traversed and so it if all of the copies
of the data that you're asking for are
sort of a Tier one away from me then
we're in trouble
and so if if people are in sort of a an
individual web crawler that sort of well
behaved is not a problem if everybody
decides to sort of crawl the web pull
out then then I think we're in deep
trouble and so that's where these sort
of you know if there are any kind of
resource controls of what the edges sort
of allow is sort of reasonable behavior
are we gonna be in trouble in tier ones
and that you know we just don't know
where that that trade-off is going to be
and then the last point is sort of if
you and this is you know hypothetically
if you think that this design might be
the right thing to do in this sort of
clean slate hypothetical future is there
anything we can do today or you know
sort of in the near future that embodies
part of this and part of the problem is
that you know the good part is we don't
change routers so we don't have to
change anything about the data path the
bad part is we change data names which
is sort of even worse because that
changes what humans use which you know
are is even more of a problem than
changing what routers do and that I
don't know how to get started meaning
you certainly you can have sort of two
parallel naming structures and
resolution structures which is I hand a
name to now I am plenty so i hand a name
to my you know sort of my my host hands
a name down and it splits off to
resolution requests one two dns one two
this infrastructure and whoever answers
first wins and sort of if done' doesn't
have it
then nothing bad has happened but that
would require you know major software
vendors to actually sort of put this
into you know in their stack that you
actually have these two separate tracks
a resolution and that users actually
register their data with donut and so
that looks very unlikely so our path to
doing this is actually to basically just
we're going to set up a bit torrent
tracker that is what we're gonna do is
set up a tracker that uses this
technology we're gonna set up you know a
set of DHS and we're gonna register
copies of the data and the sort of you
know when people want data they're going
to use our mechanism is going to be what
finds that my close copy of the data and
so that sort of the only way we see of
sort of getting this into usage without
anybody actually knowing that they're
using it that's it yeah oh so absolutely
because remember to sum I mean I should
have made this clear that this first
packet gets taken to the location of the
data and then it responds directly to
the source or to cache as if it wants to
talk to caches so if it is streaming
media it would be labeled don't cache
and then these two endpoints would talk
directly and you would have all the
application specific processing the
what you would do is you would
automatically be taken to the closest
source of that video so if I at ten
thousand source of the video I get but
but caching it doesn't happen the slight
issue would be in the signing the data
now it is harder for me to look at a
stream and know that yes indeed this
came from I I know that the first packet
might come from the source but if
somebody else starts you know being an
imposter later that sort of a signature
over the data per packet on a media
stream is probably not a realistic way
of validating the data so that so you
both lose the caching and you lose the
certifying so that if there are multiple
copies that they all register
independently and when I route for the
data I will find the closest one it is
only if I don't find any of them that I
actually am taken to the AR that the
error will take me to a copy real time
such that they can't be cached okay I
mean for video cameras and same with
that
or four telescopes watching it cosmic
event or whatever it is okay but um you
know these identical copies or open
thanks for which the four top was the
same but which the four locations vary
in network location in terms of moving
around the network by IP address but
they're all associated with the same
principle they're also a few for the
same AR and this example right and so
here trying to find the closest one I
don't think this would solve it by
itself I mean something else to find the
closest it was it's open there's two
aspects to your question let me separate
it let's assume they're not moving then
you have to have these four sources
right I will get right into the closest
one do we agree on that
no because I mean the registration
command goes up in the find command will
intercept it and I'll be taken to the
close I mean to that clients no no it
would that there is an AR that those
were all my data it let's let's assume
that that is the principal th so here
this is my my eh / AR but now there's
copy one copy - they all register with
whatever D H they happen to be located
in so this one may be in Asia this one
may be in Europe in this may one may be
in the US so any requests you know
coming from this continent will be
routed there oh yeah you're absolutely
right they register with wherever they
are
ah right right so precisely if they
registered here we have the Akamai
problem right so yes so you register
with where you are and you get routed
there
the problem that you the second part was
if they're moving then you know sort of
it's how yeah yeah exactly and and the
other thing would be if for some reason
this AR the copy it knew about was like
way over here then you may be in trouble
this is a routing to the AR yes there
was a question over here that may have
questions so most of the time you're
trying to exploit localities if you have
the data somewhere close by pick it up
from something that changes rapidly
let's say news webpage or something like
that that may be substantial overnight
because first as soon as you have
looking for that data you can try to
find everybody around you see if they
have an up-to-date copy or not and then
eventually you may just end up from the
so so let's take this
so let's say we have a piece of data
that has a short TTL meaning that this
sort of is being updated every minute so
the data source will put a TTL of one
minute that says if you get it within
one minute it's still valid then what
happens I would do a request and so
let's assume that there's only one feed
meaning that there's one data source I
would make a request and and heat cache
it would check to see whether the the
copy in the cache you know was within
its TTL or not if not I would go back
but subsequent requests within that TTL
would you know and you can do HDTV kinds
of things were if I find a copy in the
cache when I first do is I just ask the
server is this still though the valid
copy you know rather than going and
dragging it over but but it it's you
know Stan I mean that and that's it's
ten you know we're stealing everything
from HTTP way it does now well if I
don't know how to build a cache I mean
if you have a stream from here I don't I
mean if a cache decides that it wants
you know let's say it's a gigabyte file
the cache decides that a it it
understands that application level
protocol and B it's willing to stuff a
gigabyte on its disk it can cache it I
mean there's nothing preventing it but
it's just sort of caching that is a much
higher onus than normal caching
whatever caching they use can be just
used on here interacting the tool like
like a copy P live all those media
streaming real-time media streaming over
p2p networks I think they do caching
they do kinda like the file sharing I
mean so so if your D H wants to do
caching that's great it's just it's sort
of a much bigger burden than some of
these boxes may be willing to take off
but you know so it wasn't a technical
reason that it couldn't do it but it's
just sort of you're not going to be able
to cache a lot of full length movies
without getting
I'm working on
I'll be talking about for the next half
hour or so and I'm happy to take
questions any time during the talk okay
so we all know that TCP is not really
the best protocol that we can a
congestion control protocol we can have
in high bandwidth delay network it's
been demonstrated experimentally and
shown mathematically that TCP reaches
becomes very inefficient in a high
bandwidth delay product network so here
are let's quickly here's a quick recap
of some of the problems with TCP but
first of all the slow additive increase
of TCP means flows take an extremely
long time to acquire any spare capacity
in the network as a very simple example
consider a flow with a window size of
about 80,000 packets which is needed in
order for it to have a sustained rate of
7.2 gigabits per second with a
round-trip time of 100 milliseconds it
takes approximately 40,000 miles or
approximately 17 minutes in order to
recover from a single packet drop
clearly that's unacceptable in high high
speed networks second the TCP flows need
extremely and unrealistically low loss
probabilities in order to be able to
sustain high bandwidth or a continued
high bandwidth this makes it extremely
difficult for a flow to have a high
sustainable law a large sustainable
window in high speed networks and this
is a consequence once again of TCP s
slow additive increase and the drastic
multiplicative decrees and the fact that
it cannot distinguish between losses due
to congestion and uncorrectable errors
third it gets confused by low ceilings
treats them as congested networks and
under utilizes then fold it shares
bandwidth inversely proportional to the
round-trip times as a result long RTT
flows have a hard time updating their
fair share of the bandwidth they once
they are in the aimd mode they increase
their windows much more slowly and
out to the short RTD flows now while all
these are consequences of TCPS aimd it's
slow start is inefficient as well
because even when a flow is capable of
finishing within a few in order of one
rocker at times
today's t tcp slow-start makes it last
multiple round-trip times just to find
its fair share date and most often flows
finish before they reach their fair
share rate and finally it fills up any
amount of buffering available at the
bottleneck links just to find because it
uses loss as the only indication of as a
as the only indication of congestion as
a result extra buffers means extra delay
adding to the duration of flows now
there have been research efforts to
alleviate a subset of these problems
with TCP but by far one of the most
radical solutions in the literature has
been the explicit control protocol or
xcp
now the reason that I'm bringing up
about xep is this is by far the most uh
the the freshest look at congestion
controls so far and it has a good
reputation in the congestion control
literature it's proposed by kitabi and
others and is a part of the newark
project so the way it CP works is it
involves the routers in congestion
control the routers explicitly notify
the receivers the state of congestion in
the network and how to react to it and
the senders adjust their window sizes
based on this precise feedback
information that they receive so all the
new flows in xep start with a very small
window size and the picture that you
should have of xep is that in every
round-trip time flows receive a window
increment or a decrement over the
current window size and so at any point
in time different flows could have
different window sizes and different
round-trip times and therefore different
rates and they're continuously trying to
converge towards the same fair share
rate by slowly reducing the window sizes
of flows with whose rates are above the
fair share and increasing the window
sizes of flows whose rates are below the
and this convergence could take many
many rungs at times and all the while
the fair share is continuously changing
because new flows arrive and old flows
finish and all this is done while doing
extremely detailed per packet
computation at the routers so in the
rest so the main benefit of xcp over TCP
what you should take away is that it
solves all the problems with TCP that
I've talked about before so long as
flows are long enough so it solves all
the problems when there is a fixed in a
static environment of longer flows
literally having an infinite amount of
data to send and in such a scenario it
actually results in a very high 100%
link utilization it results in a fair
share of the link bandwidth and very
small queue occupancy with a near zero
packet loss but yet we believe that xev
doesn't really make much sense because
of the following reason well first of
all it achieves the ideal goal of
processor sharing in a static
environment of longer flows but actually
when there are a mix of flows it
deviates far from what it's been trying
to achieve which is trying to emulate
processor sharing in fact it becomes
unfair and inefficient and far worse
than even TCP so when there are flows of
different sizes
arriving randomly sharing a bottleneck
link it in fact makes the flows last two
orders of magnitude higher than
necessary words of many times worse off
than TCP as we'll see and all this is
done while doing very detailed per
packet computation at the routers so in
the rest of the talk what I'm gonna show
you is how we can achieve not only what
xcp does with the long glyph flows but
even more when there are a mix of flows
all while doing very little work at the
routers let's have a look at an example
in this example this example actually
compares the performance the flow
completion time of two protocols xcp and
TCP
the ideal that can be achieved but
before we get on to the example let me
tell you something about the metric that
you're using out here now if you look at
most of the literature in congestion
control it's very likely that you will
find the metrics that are being used our
link utilization or a long term of which
is a very network-centric metric or a
long term properties such as convergence
to fairness now these metrics don't make
sense for a couple of reasons first of
all they either very network-centric
such as link utilization that a user
doesn't really care about or it's a long
term property such as convergence to
fairness which only makes sense if a
flow actually lasts that long to see
this property so instead we decided to
use the metric of flow completion time
or how quickly does a flow finish from
starting from when the sender sends the
same packet to when the receiver
receives the last packet of the flow
clearly this is a more direct indication
of how the user experiences the network
so coming back to these plots what you
seen on the left hand side is a plot of
the average flow completion time versus
a subset of the flow sizes observed in
the simulation flows arrive randomly and
they have a heavy-tailed flow size
distribution out here the top plot out
here is the flow completion times under
xcp this plot out here is the flow
completion times under TCP as you can
see most of them finish up in the slow
start a few of them experience losses
and take longer to finish and this is
what flows would have finished if they
were ideally processor shared and the
one on the right-hand side shows the
number of active flows over the
simulation over time as a consequence of
TCP and xcp making the flows last much
longer than processor sharing there
consequently a larger number of flows
built up over time so in the remaining
part of the talk I'm going to show you
how we can achieve flow completion times
close to this ideal close to asset the
flows were ideally process of shared
while doing extremely little work at the
routers
yes this has been simulation the setup
is it's a high bandwidth delay products
so the link capacities 2.4 gigabits per
second and if the long trip time is 100
milliseconds in this particular case is
for a single bottleneck case but it
really doesn't make much of difference
so what are the qualities that we would
like if we are to design a congestion
control mechanism well first of all we
would like to ideally emulate processor
sharing then we would like to be asked
we we want to be as close to processor
sharing as if the flows were ideally
processor shared why processor sharing
is actually a very nice a very nice
property to have well first of all
because it's performance is invariant of
the flow size distribution at least for
a single link case second it actually
results in flows finishing very quickly
in fact quite close to the best that can
be achieved and third even if there are
only long flow suppose there are no mix
of flows then it actually results in
100% link utilization and the link
bandwidth being very fairly utilized oh
utilized in a fair manner the second
property that we would want is we want
we would want the network to be stable
irrespective of in the sense that it
converges to some equilibrium operating
behavior if there is one irrespective of
the network conditions such as
topologies or round-trip times or the
link capacities or the traffic
conditions such as the mix of flows long
flows shot flows and so on and finally
we would ideally want to achieve these
properties without any pure flow State
or per flow queuing or any complex per
packet computations at the routers
so our CP is our CP stands for rate
control protocol the approach in our CP
is slightly different from that of TCP
or XE B instead of giving a incremental
window change in every round trip time
the question we are asking is is there
an explicit rate the router can hand out
to the flows so as to emulate processor
sharing if we are to offer one rate to
all the flows what would that rate be
now if the router really knew the exact
number of flows at every instant of time
and all the flows were bottleneck at
that particular router then this
question is really very simple the
router should just give C over n to all
the flows and be done and if there was
no feedback delay between then this
would reach the the sources
instantaneously and this would solve the
problem but unfortunately it's hard to
keep track of the exact value of n at
the routers and even if it would keep
track of n by the time this information
reaches the source there is a feedback
delay so n would have changed anyways
and further different flows have
different amounts of data to send and
they are bottleneck at different points
so n doesn't really make much sense
estimating the exact value of n doesn't
make sense which is why we propose that
our CP be an adaptive algorithm that
updates the rate that it offers to the
flows without keeping track of n without
any knowledge of N in the presence of
feedback delay with without keeping any
information on the number of flows so it
is a particular heuristic which is
designed to approximate processor
sharing in the presence of in the
absence of this information and in the
presence of feedback delay it has to
remain characteristics that actually
make it very appealing one of them first
is the rate is picked by the routers
just based upon the aggregate incoming
traffic and the queue size information
second the router offers a single rate
to all the flows passing through it and
finally it doesn't need any state or any
per flow queuing and very minimal per
packet computations
so the basic mechanism is as you would
have imagined by now that every router
maintains a single rate are that it
updates periodically say for now once
every average round-trip time of the
flows passing through this passing
through that length every source before
starting sends a syn packet in which it
in which it sets the rate that it would
like to transmit at and it could set it
arbitrarily high and as this scent
passes through the network if the rate
at the router is lower than what is
there in the same packet there it
overrides it so by the time it reaches
the receiver it has the lowest rate
corresponding to the most congested link
along the path and this is echoed back
to the receiver and to the sender and
the sender starts transmitting at that
rate and thereafter every data packet is
that this rate is piggybacked in every
data and the act packets so the sender
keeps getting an updated rate from the
network even if the flow lasts longer
than a round-trip time apart from this
every packet also carries of the
sender's estimate of its round-trip time
and the routers use that to maintain -
to maintain their average of the long
trip time of the flows passing through a
particular interface so let's look at
the exact algorithm that the routers use
in order to update this rate R now in
order to emulate process of sharing
intuitively you just need to do three
things or first of all you need to offer
a single rate to all the flows second
you need to fill up the outgoing link
for traffic and third you need to keep
the queue occupancy small and this is
the intuition base that this that which
forms the basis for this equation out
here so R is the rate that is updated by
the router at time T d0 is the average
round-trip time that is maintained by
the router round-trip time of the flows
passing through ad so R of T minus d0 is
the rate that it offered in the previous
control interval C is the link capacity
y is the aggregate
incoming traffic queue is the the
current queue occupancy alpha and beta
are parameters chosen for stability and
for performance and n hat of T is the
routers estimate of the number of flows
we'll we'll see how it how it maintains
that so all this equation is trying to
do is if there is spare capacity
available that a C minus y of T is
greater than zero increase the rate
evenly amongst all the flows on the
other hand if the link is over
subscribed that a C minus y of T is less
than zero or there is a queue built up
then decrease the rate of all the flows
evenly so you can think of the numerator
as the aggregate amount of traffic
change that you want to bring about in
the next control interval and by
dividing that by your estimate of the
number of flows you you arrive at the
per flow rate now the router does not
know the exact number of flows so we
estimate it as C divided by the rate of
the previous round trip time now I'll
come to you shortly as to why this is a
good estimate and when it can be bad and
if it's bad why we don't need a good
estimate and alpha and beta as I said
are parameters for stability and
performance there's one more change to
this basic equation which is we would
like to update the rate more often than
a round-trip time because after all if a
queue is building up why wait for an
entire round-trip time before reducing
the rate you might as well reduce the
rate so that the newly arriving flows
can get a smaller rate so as a result we
update the rate more often say once
every T seconds where T is typically the
order of 10 milliseconds so it updates
at the rate at the minimum of a
user-defined parameter T and the average
round-trip time since we updated more
often we correspondingly bring about a
smaller change for every aggregate
update so you updated more often but
correspondingly do a smaller change each
time and that's why we scaled this
aggregate change by T divided by d0
and there are the small changes like
this gamma for example controls the
linking the target link utilization we
might not want to operate the link at a
hundred percent target utilization but
instead would like to leave some
Headroom for any surge in traffic to
drain away so this is the rate of debt
equation that is used by the routers to
offer understand yes yes so so that
would be what what what it would reduce
to if if you do this algorithm update it
actively would be it would do fee - take
away the traffic that is not responding
to the RCP congestion control so it
would do C - divide that traffic divided
by the that's what the equations would
become
you don't need to keep her floats you're
saying that right well all I'm saying is
that suppose I have a flow suppose I
have a UDP flow that is just blasting at
whatever rates on and it's essentially
your see in this case the arse
it just becomes C - the unresponsive
flow but the capacitor needs to be set
to a value because you have to see -
wild feet arms so if it's just taken
care of that
we can pick it up plan okay actually I
have I'm gonna copy that
so let's let's understand some things
about the algorithms we're supposed to
fall how good is the estimate C / R now
when there are only long left flows in
the network then C / R is actually a
very good estimate of the number of the
exact number of n for example here there
are 20 long flows which start at time 0
and 20 more flow start at 9:40 and in
each case C / are converging well in
this case what's plotted is r / c
converges to 1 over n which is 0.05 here
in point O 2 5 out here and the 20 flows
depart in this case finish a time
hundred now even if flows are not long
but suppose the mean flow length is
comparable to the bandwidth delay
product that is the mean flow size is is
about equal or greater than C times RT T
then even then Co where R is a good
estimate of the number of flows as it's
plotted out here the number of active
flows versus time when the mean flow
size is comparable to the panwa delay
product is just a noisy estimate because
flows are arriving quickly and departing
so the real question is what happens
when the mean flow size is actually very
small compared to the bandwidth delay
product because here most of the flows
do not have at least a round-trip time
worth of data to send and in this case C
/ R underestimates the number of flows
but under estimating the number of flows
and thereby giving a higher rate to
every flow is actually the right thing
to do because if most of us do not have
at least a round-trip time worth of data
to send then giving exactly C / n to
every flow is not going to fill up the
bottleneck link capacity our CP doesn't
change the way in which loss the loss is
detected that's pretty much that's done
the way TCP does it currently and the
its parameters alpha and beta can be
chosen for in order to make our CP
stable for a very broad range of network
and traffic conditions I'll come to
welcome to how we choose its parameters
alpha and beta
let's have a look at some performance
results of our CP so we test with the
performance what I'm going to show you
our simulation results but as to the
performance of our CP on a very wide
traffic characteristics such as when
under different flow size distributions
are the different flow arrival patterns
under different Network loads and so on
and under different network conditions
such as different topologies when flows
with very heterogeneous round-trip times
share shared links under multiple
bottleneck links can reverse congested
links and so on and in every case the
performance metric that we were
interested in is the average flow
completion time where the flow
completion time is the time interval
between when the sender sends the syn
packet to when the receiver receives the
last packet of the flow an average flow
completion time is just the mean over a
subset of the flow sizes observed in the
simulation and in every case we were
interested in comparing it to TCP xvp
and that of the ideal process of sharing
which can be just computed by this
expression out here where it takes at
least one RTD for the since enak set up
0.5 RT t at least for the data exchange
plus the mean flow length divided by the
link capacity times 1 minus Rho where
Rho is the offered load so this is what
we compare it to in every case an each
case you will find that our CP sets out
the goals that we've set out before
achieve the goals that we've set out
before well this is an example where the
setup is a high bandwidth delay
environment where the link capacity is
2.4 gigabits per second the round-trip
time is 80 milliseconds what you're
seeing out here is the y-axis is a flow
completion time versus a subset of the
flow sizes observed in the simulation
this is just the range from 0 to 2000
packets and this is the larger flow
sizes there are three distinct lines out
here what you find out here is the
topmost line is X ep
then is TCP the green line is TCP and
this is the blue line as RCP and you
also find what what's also plotted is
the process of sharing delay and the
delay that flows would have taken if
they finished completely in slow start
so in this particular case RCP TCP is
about five times higher in xep is about
thirty times higher and RCP does very
close to processor sharing what's also
shown out here in the bottom plot is the
maximum flow completion time for any
given flow size so it's not just that
the average is close to processor
sharing but actually the maximum flow
completion time for any flow under RCP
is also close to processor sharing
whereas in case of TCP then the variance
is pretty high the maximum is often ten
times above the mean notice that
although xcp was primarily designed for
longer flows but when there are a mix of
flows it actually does badly for all of
them for short and for the long live now
it's it would be unfair to say that
actually xep always performs worse off
than TCP because that isn't so I mean if
you keep increasing the mean of the mean
flow size relative to the bandwidth
delay product then xcp begins to perform
better than TCP because this is
precisely the regime that it was
designed to perform well where there are
a few multiplex a few high bandwidth
flows multiplexed in a network and
that's the region where TCP begins to
perform much worse off as shown in this
example out here where the back the mean
bandwidth delay product is comparable to
the bandwidth delay product of the
network in case of RCP it makes no
difference because there are no
assumptions on the mean flow size
so if you actually look at what is it
about these protocols that give such
vastly different characteristics then
here's what you will find
so what's shown out here is a plot of
the sequence number evolution versus
time for these different four randomly
sample flows for these three protocols
first notice that in case of TCP most of
the flows it's very likely that you will
find most of the flows just finish off
and slow start some of them experience
losses and take longer to finish and if
they could get into the aimd phase they
are extremely slow in catching up with
spare capacity and take many times
longer to complete whereas in case of
RCP they received the best the they
receive the best equilibrium rate that
the router thinks should be the
equilibrium rate and they finish up
quickly xeb actually takes many times
longer than tcp in most of the cases in
in almost all the cases that we've tried
out so flow start extremely slowly and
they receive they ramp up very slowly
over time in general it makes the flows
last many round-trip times just to avoid
oversubscription
and to keep the queue occupancy slow
well our RC B on the other hand
runs up fast at the expense of a
temporary bandwidth oversubscription so
this is just another the last of the
examples where I'm gonna show you where
the results are not are not dependent
upon the flow size distribution so far
I've showed you with heavy tail flow
sizes and this is just the case with
exponentially distributed flow sizes so
it's process of sharing emulation is
independent of what mix of flows flow
sizes you offer to RCP
so the other property that I'd mentioned
where that is desirable of a congestion
control protocol is that it is stable in
respective of the network and traffic
conditions stable in the sense that if
there is an equilibrium operating point
we want the protocol to converge to that
equilibrium point and remain there and
even if perturbed it should come back to
the equilibrium point now in case of our
CP it turns out that its parameters
alpha and beta can be chosen to make it
stable independent of the network and
the traffic conditions so for example
the way to interpret this graph is that
so long as you choose alpha and beta on
to the left of this red dotted line the
system is stable independent of the link
capacities the round-trip time and the
number of flaws so the two regions which
are plotted out here one is the blue the
blue shaded region just shows the lead
the stable region of a linearized system
but it turns out that actually if you
take the non-linearity of the system
into consideration and do a stability
analysis the nonlinear stable region
turns out to be larger and encapsulate
the linear stable region which is shown
on but on to the left-hand side of the
red dotted line so what this says is we
don't need to expend too much effort in
choosing the parameters alpha and beta
and this is very important because we
know the number of papers army written
to tune the parameters of red and TCP
so there are some other problems that
we've thought about given thought under
our CP which I won't have time to
mention for example this is what happens
is it stable when flows arrive randomly
in depart randomly so that stability
under flow arrivals and departures what
happens when how do you give waited
bandwidth sharing two flows or how much
what are the buffer requirements for our
CP so we've thought about all those but
I won't be presenting it here today so
let me just quickly go through the
implementation of our CP so our CP is
being the router algorithm is being
implemented on that FPGA so net FPGA is
a system bill in next group with and
it's used for two main purposes one is
to help it helps in teaching networking
system design and two it it's a platform
for researchers in order to prototype
their ideas in networking so it's just a
simple a PCI boat they can that plugs
into any of the modern pcs and it has
four Ethernet interface cards each
running at one gigabit per second and
one of the things that was built upon it
for example it's a fully functional ipv4
router and our CP was implemented on top
of this router now there are two parts
to the implementation of our CP
algorithm one is the P algorithm that's
executed periodically in order to update
the rate R and that is done in software
and two are the per packet computations
that are done on every packet basis now
those are very simple they're
essentially only three things that one
needs to do this just this diagram of
here shows the data path of an RCP
packet essentially one needs to find out
whether the incoming packet is an RCP
packet does it have a valid round-trip
time if it has added to the running sum
of the outgoing interface and if the
rate carried in the RCP packet is
greater than the rate that can be
offered by the router overwrite it so in
the worst case it
about two additions or multiplication
and a comparison
the end host is being implemented in
Linux well for now we have the RCP
congestion header as shim header between
the IP and the transport it's 12 bytes
which has fields for the the RCP
bottleneck rate information in the
forward direction the eco from the
receiver to the sender in the reverse
direction and the sender's estimate of
the round-trip time and in TCP there is
an RCP pluggable congestion control
module which just uses this information
from the RCP header and modulates the
senders congestion window and faces
packets as well the other
functionalities of TCP suggests at state
machine and the loss detection
mechanisms remain unchanged
so our plants now our plants henceforth
from over the next quarter or so is a to
demonstrate our CP on a test bed with
multiple routers to demonstrate it under
more under both different traffic
conditions and different traffic
patterns both benign and under
challenging traffic conditions so we're
also currently working on an internet
draft for our CP that actually brings to
the end of my talk so to conclude TCP is
not suitable for a high bandwidth delay
environment it becomes inefficient there
have been many proposals but by far xvp
has been the boldest attempt but it
hasn't set out but it hasn't achieved
what it set out to do as a result there
is no congestion control algorithm today
that can make flows finish fast in a
high bandwidth Network just making the
network faster is not going to help if
the flow completion time is limited by
the number of round-trip times that the
congestion control protocols make the
flows last it's our premise that a good
way to design congestion control is by
closely emulating processor sharing by
that the flow completion times are close
to the minimum achievable and our CP is
a heuristic to achieve that the
consequences of that would be flows
would finish much faster several times
faster than TCP and xcp
it's inherently fair among the flows
it's probably stable independent of the
network and traffic conditions it's easy
to please flows easy to give
differential services differential
bandwidth sharing amongst flows and I
see as you've seen it's easy to
implement as well at least the router
implementation is not hard
so that's the end
you can see mentioned that the RCPD
boots are starting up is this a
theoretical issue is it something that
we'd actually be worried about I mean
it's the amount of synchronous
Susanville whole bunch of flows all
start at the same time so that is like
the really worst case scenario for RCT
there a lot of high bandwidth flows just
start in a Kwan's well first of all it
doesn't matter the number of flows what
really matters is the amount of
aggregate traffic so actually I have a
flaw to quickly illustrate that so this
so this partly no it doesn't matter it's
just a total limb
how does it matter if I have a thousand
flows each having one all I'm saying is
that what matters is the total amount of
traffic that the flows carry if I have a
thousand flows having one packet to send
they might not really congested outer
yeah it's the aggregate amount of
traffic anything that you react
basically my definition of a flow here
is anything that whatever the router is
stamping in a rate are in every packet
so whatever unit reacts to this rate R
and and cents in packets at the radar is
a flow so it could be a TCP level flow
no I mean they're both they're all
receiving a rate R so each one of them
is going to pace its packets at rate R
so they're too close
and your router doesn't well if my music
is used you have to copy the congestion
header from on to the encapsulating
header and at the D capsule a ting point
you have to copy it back on to the inner
header
so this is an example to answer the
question where actually a the network is
the network utilization is high it's at
100% and suddenly a whole lot of flow
starting at once
in fact the network load just doubles
within our own trip time so as you can
see there is a spike in the queue and I
should tell you what I've plotted out
here what's on the top plot is the link
utilization versus time what's plotted
in the middle plot is the queue
occupancy versus time and what's plotted
out here is the rate versus time so the
rate reduces in response to this queue
spike in the queue but then it builds
back and this and the the time in which
it builds back is actually in the order
of about five round-trip times in which
it finds the new fair share rate so our
CP doesn't optimize the system for the
case where there is a sudden influx of
traffic but it recovers from it quickly
yes boostedgt
you movie is for the lower as much the
people equipment to prepare bo is the
stage of the right it doesn't matter you
can just choose any initial community
yes it's independent it's the only
important X so you can you choose a
trade knowledge so everyone goes to
Falacci sorry I mean let's consider a
simple case that is one what neck so the
if you choose this any issue it is
tonight so ever and catch every yeah and
then you settle down to your fair share
take for example in this case if you see
we just chose our 0 as 1 over 20th of
the link but as you can see it doesn't
matter in a few RT T's it will it will
find what the correct R is there is no
explicit reaction to packet loss because
you are already getting you are getting
explicit information from the router on
if they if the arc is because it stamped
in every act packet and every data
packet so in the worst case it's like
all the data packets and all the act
packets need to be lost for you not to
have any feedback in the wrong crypt
time and actually if the at the center
side the protocol is that if it doesn't
get air feedback in the wrong time it
sends in probe packets very small probe
packets
well what happens in a world before all
robbers have the RCP stamping some
matters they do it well so long as the
congestion congestion points have it it
it makes sense
you imagine that here I mean there are
there are a whole bunch of questions
addressed here which are related to what
what does it mean have incremental
appointment what happens we have ground
that has TCP and Osby
go existing or happens about
I think it's always the easiest way to
think of this is that what does it mean
for an end host Rob right to an
apartment where some of the top he could
imagine
at the point of a decision said that
says I will find an easy way where I
prove in my sin as to whether that's
also be and if there's not I just use
overtly the easiest one in some cases
it's very obvious what a bottle like
here's the bottle like this between
so it's really a question of figuring
out whether there's LCD
my cable provider or DSL
so it might be that something
the obvious choice of any maintenance
as soon as a router actually has a CB in
it it wants to operate with both our CPM
TCP it would make most sense of having
made decision it would on CP to also
have an Aussie be cute if I for
provides a little bit more about
I guess I'm not actually essential but
it will but I guess the concern was more
actually the races
and what if I have RCP not on our
speedometer not on the model like
lightning but actually on a fairly fast
line and so now if I of TCP and our city
is flowing through the RCP stamp set as
hey there's lots of bandwidth but
realize that the bottom like it's on
their place the RCP traffic going
through those those links will
absolutely crush the traffic
right see no see you're saying that
there is our CP is not being used there
are two links and our CP is not know so
let's say I have a serial chain of
routers and there's a non our CP router
a thin length which is that true
bottleneck link then an RCP router and a
thick link so if I have both TCP and our
CP flows flowing through these two
routers our CP is going to be adapting
itself or the pasady of the bat-line
sending off the traffic because the thin
link is absolutely right because the
thing throughout the thing gives it was
not properly stamping the RCPD
yes but that gets back to what Nick said
that you you need a mechanism to grow
beforehand if the entire path can
support us and eat okay
and for example of the the mechanism
that's used in solid fluid problems of
the QuickStart is to have a quick stop
PDL and an IPL and every router which
understands quick starter supposed to do
that's another way so you can use an
invariant property of the algorithm
because if there are losses or there is
excessive queuing delay then RCT will
reduce the rate but if the client is not
seeing anything like that then it
obviously means that the congested
things are not support obsolete you
would like
not every top does ICP but the hops of
donors of solar provisions of math I
have a comment
they tells about the interaction with an
RCP in TCP if you're using our CPU kind
of regime that the sender is not going
to react to packet plus it has our CP is
going to cause packet loss during its
convergence period whereas when you're
falling back on to TCP TCP senders
actually use and packet loss of the only
signal of contention so there seems to
be like no good way of deciding when to
shift from an RCP to TCP I like what
Nick was saying which is like if the
whole path was our CPU but then you
could just go ahead and use our CP
anyway because suppose I am receiving on
the RCP source and I am receiving
continuous rate of days an unseen packet
loss now it is you need to decide when
you are gonna let the RCP suppose that I
the bottleneck the throw out in front of
the bottleneck is actually I say that it
does not react the packet loss what I
need to say the souls doesn't react to
packet loss explicitly but you can have
a mechanism in which if I'm continuously
receiving a rate R that's either
increasing or about the same but an
unseen bottleneck an active losses then
that means you have to good yeah because
our CP by the invariance of the RCP our
algorithm is that I've known as soon as
there's a queue build-up it reduces the
way
you'd have to wait for I mean there are
complications that can happen right you
could you could assume that the AK is
not coming back or the axon the t-birds
path get lost at that signal at
decreasing rate so it becomes a little
tricky as to what really need a large a
very large number of acts or data
buckets to get lost
in order for that at the same rate you
start with every packet
so if one flow the radius out of control
the artists
and receive an act
make the whole night
one flow is well okay first of all if
there are no acts coming off say our
city is our city also has a window size
right so if there are no acts coming up
it is not just going to continuously
blasts because there is it does follow
the window principles as well yeah
so it is not that you just if you are
not receiving acts you are continuously
tossing into the network you stopped
when
you